happy holidays and happy new year i am
super excited to have a fresh start to
the year
after all that holiday indulging join me
on a three week
clean eating meal plan to reset and help
you get back on track
i'm in partnership with lifesome a
nutrition focused app which helps you
keep track of your healthy habits
by logging your meals exercise and water
intake
so before we continue be sure to
download life sum with the links below
and follow along there are two links
one is a free version for you to try out
the other is a discount link for the
premium version
where you'll have access to the full
features in the app
forget about the crazy restrictive clans
instead
kick start your healthy eating habits
with easy to follow meal plans and
recipes on live sum
at the end of these 3 weeks you should
feel energized and motivated to continue
on with your healthy habits
what i love about the app is the broad
selection of different meal plans
which fits to your own preferences you
can even take a simple test
to find out what plan suits you so i'm
going to follow the clean eating plan
and i'll be sharing with you three of my
favorite recipes
chia and oat pudding for breakfast
seared salmon
and mango salad for lunch and tofu soup
for dinner all the ingredients and steps
are clearly laid out
and very easy to follow so let's start
with
breakfast here are the ingredients
you'll need
there are only two simple steps mix all
the ingredients together
in a bowl except the fresh berries
let it sit for about 20 minutes or i
like to leave it
overnight in the fridge the next morning
when i'm ready to eat i'll simply top it
up with some fresh
berries it is that simple
i love this recipe because i get to plan
and prep ahead
which helps me to start my day stress
free now
let's move on to lunch seat salmon and
mango salad
here's what you'll need this recipe is
really simple too
let's start by cooking the salmon you
can choose to pan fry
personally i prefer to bake them preheat
the oven to 185 degrees
celsius place the salmo fillets onto a
baking tray
and bake for 20 minutes or until the
salmon are fully cooked
through while waiting for the salmon to
cook let's prep the salad
so i'm going to slice the mango into
cubes
and read bell pepper into smaller pieces
in a bowl
combine the rice together with the mango
bell pepper corn
chili flakes sesame seeds and
season with a little bit of soy sauce
mix until
all the ingredients are well combined
then transfer to a plate
and serve with a piece of salmon fillet
i love this recipe as it has a good
balance of protein
carbs and healthy fat it is very
colorful
appetizing and delicious this makes a
very satisfying dish
if you want to bring this out with you
you can simply separate the mango and
rice
salad with the salmon as for dinner i
like to have something
warm and light let's make tofu soup
here are the ingredients this recipe is
extremely simple as
it is a one pot dish and you can easily
adjust the quantity
to cook for a large family let's start
by prepping
all the vegetables so let's slice the
tofu
bell pepper and onion into smaller
pieces
time to cook heat the pot with a little
bit of olive oil
then add the onions and fry them for a
couple of minutes until they are golden
brown and fragrant
then stir in the broccoli beans
vegetable stock and tomato paste
allow it to cook for about 5 minutes
then stir in the tofu
and season with paprika powder herbs and
a little bit of salt
bring to a boil and let it simmer for
another 10 minutes until the vegetables
are tender
serve warm and garnish with some fresh
parsley
what i love about this recipe is that
it's extremely versatile i can choose to
add
other proteins such as fish or chicken
and
even add other vegetables such as
carrots and potatoes
these are just three of my favorite
recipes there are a lot more recipes
in the meal plan so you don't have to
worry about feeling bored eating the
same food
over and over again another feature i
love about using livestock is that
i'm able to immediately track all my
meals and to know how many calories i've
consumed for the day
for instance based on all these three
meals and also my snack
which is a banana and a handful of
almond nuts i've consumed a total of
1754 calories they also have
a detailed nutrition information for
each meal allowing me to also track my
macros
and know if i'm consuming enough too
little or too much carbs
protein and fat knowing and keeping
track of what and how much
you consume will help you to achieve
your fitness goal
whether it's to lose weight gain weight
or to increase in lean muscles
remember that eating a well-balanced
diet and staying healthy is a long-term
lifestyle change
with the right strategy and tools this
will lead to success
so don't forget to download the
lifestyle app for free
using the links below or you can even
subscribe to their premium plan
and get discounts and let's start
this year strong all the best
[Music]
you